hey what's up my name is samuel leeds in
this video i'm going to be talking about
rent to rent
and why now is a brilliant opportunity
to control
properties get cash flow on rent to rent
and
i'm even in this video gonna give you
the scripts
to say to landlords how to approach
landlords and what to say to them this
is usually the kind of stuff that i'll
save for my property investors crash
course but i'm going to give it to you
on this video
but please do me a massive favor smash
the like button
also as well as hitting like please do
subscribe to the channel
turn the notification bell on and that
way when i make a video for you you
don't
miss it because you've turned on the
subscribe and the notification bell
button
um okay so rent events what rent to rent
is is when you control a property
instead of owning a property
you pay the landlord a monthly rent and
you pay it
as a management agreement so you have a
corporate let
namely your company rents the property
off of the landlord you don't rent it
that would be called sub-letting so your
company rents the property off the
landlord
and you pay a small monthly rent and
then
you rent the property out and you put
people maybe maybe you rent
out on booking.com you put guests in the
house on shortstaylets
on airbnb on booking.com and then you
you get a super rent
and all of the profit guess what you
keep the profit so most rent to rent
properties make between 500 and 1000
pounds profit
per month off each rent to rent property
that's more
profit off of the rent to rent houses
than most landlords make when they own
the house
so why would you save up and buy a house
and rent it out and make a couple few
hundred pounds a month
and you're hit with all the tax problems
with section 24
you've got to pay stamp duty tax why do
that
well you can just do rent to rent and
control a property
now the two reasons people don't like
doing rent to rents number one
is because they can't get their
insurance they say well what do i say to
the landlord how do i persuade the
landlord
in this video i'm going to tell you
exactly what to say to the landlord
and the second reason people don't like
to ants is because they say oh but
serviced accommodation shorts they let
tourism's a bit dead right now we've
been in lockdown it's risky
so let me tell you how to get around
those two problems number one
the risky problem of the tourism being
dead and what happens if i can't rent
the properties out two things i'll say
number one is don't get tourists in your
properties advertise them to business
professionals
number two have a three-month break
clause in the property
with the agreement so that if after
three months it's not working
you can walk away make sure the brake
clause is drawn up properly
and make sure that the brake clause
doesn't let him walk away without
reimbursing you with your time and
troubles
okay so that's that second thing is
how do you get these properties how do
you speak to landlords this is so simple
i'm tempted to just stop doing this
video and go go and get one
i'm tempted to just go and do a
financial freedom challenge tomorrow i
might i might
i'm probably gonna be banned from
youtube soon anyway they keep talking
about banning me all the time they don't
like this stuff
okay but this is what you do right now
landlords have never been so desperate
to pass you properties on rent to rent
contracts
now you might not know that you might
think but i've tried and i failed
because you're saying the wrong thing
you're saying the wrong thing
when you learn not to say the right
thing it works i'm gonna take on this
video right now
this is what you should be saying in
order to do business with someone you
need to firstly solve their problem
if you go to a landlord and you say
landlord you've got a problem you need
me to rent your property he's going to
go
actually i'm good thanks rents have gone
up by 7.5
this year cues of tenants are coming up
i don't need
your corporate rent to rent you're good
that's what they'll say to you
so what you need to do you need to
remind them
about the tenant eviction ban you need
to remind them about tenants rights
hey landlord how much you looking to get
for your for your property
for your studio flat i'm looking to rent
it out for 550 pounds a month okay
okay cool so what are you going to be
left with once you pay
your management fees your maintenance
costs what are you looking to be left
with
well management's ten percent
maintenance i probably looking to be at
about 400 pounds
okay cool how about this then how about
uh no
i'll pay you 400 pounds a month
guaranteed rent for three years
how does that sound i don't know i don't
know i've got lots of tenants interested
oh is this a rent-to-rent thing i'm not
really interested i don't know
email me the details i'll call you back
i'll think about it let me talk to my
wife and talk to my lawyer let me talk
to my dog i'm good
that's what happens to most people so
you need to remind them of the problem
do you know these tenants that want to
move into your house what are you going
to do if they don't pay rent oh i'll
evict them you do realize you can't
evict them
do you realize that until march next
year you can't even
evict a tenant for not paying rent and
do you realize that even
after the eviction ban finishes they're
not even the courts aren't going to be
interested
in tenants that aren't paying rent
they're only going to be interested in
tenants that are being threatening or
abusive
so if you've got a tenant that just goes
i'm not going to pay rent you might have
a property for a year
where you cannot get the tenant out
yeah it's a bit of a problem as a
landlord isn't it it is so
here's what i'm proposing i'll pay you
400 pounds a month
guaranteed rent the difference between
me and a tenant is i'm not a tenant
i am a company this is a company let
so if i don't pay you you can terminate
the contract
and and this is business to business so
you haven't got to worry about tenants
you're dealing with a business you
haven't got to worry about the attendant
eviction ban you've got to worry about
late costs
late fees or any of that so
it sounds like a pretty good service to
be honest in fact there's a queue of
landlords that i'm actually going to be
approaching
over the next couple of days so i mean
what are you thinking
that's how you get rent to rent this is
easy it's all about what to say
people accuse me samuel makes it look
too easy thank you for the compliment
in the same way that cristiano ronaldo
makes football look easier that's how i
make property look easy
i'm gonna be running the crash course if
you haven't been to the property
investors crash cause it's two days
where rather than me talking about this
stuff you'll get to see me doing it
you get to see me on stage making phone
calls booking viewings doing this stuff
if you want to attend the crash course
it's free but
spaces are limited i'll leave a link in
the description
i'll see you there thanks for watching
you can subscribe right here
wasn't that awesome and you can book on
the crash course right here there should
be a link if there's not
in the description get booked i'll see
you there kick ass
make the most of these times peace out